so just for fun let me ask you a topic
of autonomous vehicles it's the area
that that I work at least these days
most closely on it's also area that I
think is a good example that you use a
sort of an example of things we as
humans don't always realize how hard it
is to do it's like the the constant
trend AI or the different problems that
we think are easy when we first try them
and then realize how hard it is okay so
why you've talked about this autonomous
driving being a difficult problem more
difficult than we realize you must give
it credit for why is it so difficult one
of the most difficult parts in your view
I think it's difficult because of the
world is so open-ended as to what what
kinds of things can happen
so you have sort of what normally
happens which is just you drive along
and nothing nothing surprising happens
and autonomous vehicles can do the ones
we have now evidently can do really well
on most normal situations as long as
long as you know the weather is
reasonably good and everything but if
some we have this notion of edge cases
or or you know things in the tail of the
distribution you can call it the long
tail problem which says that there's so
many possible things that can happen
that was not in the training data of the
machine that it won't be able to handle
it because it doesn't have common sense
right it's the old paddle moved yeah
it's the paddle moved problem right and
so my understanding and you probably are
more of an expert than I am on this is
that current self driving car vision
systems have problems with obstacles
meaning that they don't know which
obstacles which quote unquote obstacles
they should stop for and which ones they
shouldn't stop for and so a lot of times
I read
they tend to slam on the brakes quite a
bit and the most common accidents with
self-driving cars are people rear-ending
them because they were surprised they've
warned expecting the machine the car to
stop yeah so there's there's a lot of
interesting questions there whether
because because you mentioned kind of
two things so one is the the problem of
perception of understanding of
interpreting the objects that are
detected right correctly and the other
one is more like the policy the action
that you take how you respond to it so a
lot of the cars braking is the kind of
notion of to clarify there's a lot of
different kind of things that are people
calling autonomous vehicles but a lot
the L for vehicles with a safety driver
are the ones like way Moe and cruise and
those companies they tend to be very
conservative and cautious so they tend
to be very very afraid of hurting
anything or anyone and getting in any
kind of accidents so their policy is
very kind of that it that results in
being exceptionally responsive to
anything that could possibly be an
obstacle right right which which which
the human drivers around it it's
unpredictably yeah that's not a very
human thing to do caution that's not the
thing we're good at specially in driving
we're in a hurry often angry and etc
especially in Boston so and then there's
sort of another and a lot of times
that's machine learning is not a huge
part of that it's it's becoming more and
more unclear to me how much you you know
sort of speaking to public information
because a lot of companies say they're
doing deep learning and machine learning
just attract good candidates the reality
is in many cases it's still not a huge
part of the the perception this is this
lidar there's other sensors that are
much more reliable for obstacle
detection and then there's Tesla
approach which is vision only and
there's I think a few companies doing
that but s the most sort of famously
pushing that forward and that's because
the
too expensive right well I I mean yes
but I would say if you were to for free
give to every test vehicle
I mean Elon Musk fundamentally believes
that lidar is a crutch right fantasy
said that that if you want to solve the
problem of machine learning lidar is not
should not be the primary sensor is the
belief okay the camera contains a lot
more information
mm-hmm so if you want to learn you want
that information but if you want to not
to hit obstacles you want like are right
sort of it's this weird trade-off
because yeah it's sort of what Tesla
vehicles have a lot of which is really
the thing the price the fallback the
primary fallback sensor is radar which
is a very crude version of lighter it's
a good detector of obstacles except when
those things are standing right the
stopped vehicle right that's why it had
problems with crashing into stop fire
trucks stop fire trucks right so the
hope there is that the vision sensor
would somehow catch that and infer
there's a lot of problems of perception
I they are doing actually some
incredible stuff in the almost like an
active learning space where it's
constantly taking edge cases and pulling
back in there's just a data pipeline
another aspect that is really important
that people are studying now is called
multitask learning which is sort of
breaking apart this problem whatever the
problem is in this case driving into
dozens or hundreds of little problems
that you can turn into learning problems
so this giant pipeline the you know it's
kind of interesting I've I've been
skeptical from the very beginning but
become less than less skeptical over
time how much of driving can be learned
I'm still think it's much farther than
then the CEO of that particular company
thinks it will be but it it is costly
surprising
through good engineering and data
collection and active selection of data
how you can attack that long tail and
it's an interesting open question that
you're absolutely right there's a much
longer tail and all these edge cases
that we don't think about but it's this
it's a fascinating question that applies
to natural language in all spaces how
big how how big is that long tail right
and I mean not to linger on the point
but what's your sense in driving in
these practical problems of the human
experience can it be learned so the
current what are your thoughts are sort
of Elon Musk thought let's forget the
thing that he says would be solved in a
year but can it be solved in in a
reasonable timeline or do fundamentally
other methods need to be invented so I I
don't I think that ultimately driving so
so it's a trade-off in a way I you know
being able to drive and deal with any
situation that comes up does require
kind of full human intelligence and even
in humans aren't intelligent enough to
do it because humans I mean most human
accidents are are because the human
wasn't paying attention or the humans
drunk or whatever and not because they
weren't intelligent not because they
weren't intelligent enough right
whereas the accidents with autonomous
vehicles is because they weren't
intelligent enough they're always paying
attention always paying attention so
it's a it's a trade-off you know and I
think that it's a very fair thing to say
that autonomous vehicles will be
ultimately safer than humans because
humans are very unsafe it's kind of a
low bar but just like you said the III I
think he was got a bad rap right cuz
we're really good at the common sense
thing yeah we're great at the common
sense thing we're bad at the paying
attention thing I think it's a sure
thing especially morale you know driving
is kind of boring and we have these
phones to play with and everything but
I think what what's gonna happen is that
for many reasons not just AI reasons but
also like legal and other reasons that
the definition of self-driving is gonna
change our autonomous is going to change
it's not going to be just I'm gonna go
to sleep in the back and you just drive
me anywhere it's gonna be more certain
areas are going to be instrumented to
have the sensors and the mapping and all
the stuff you need for that that the
autonomous cars won't have to have full
common sense and they'll do just fine in
those areas as long as pedestrians don't
mess with them too much that's another
question I don't think we will have
fully autonomous self-driving in the way
that like most the average person thinks
of it for a very long time and just to
reiterate this is the interesting open
question that I think I agree with you
on is to solve fully autonomous driving
you have to be able to engineer in
common sense yes I think that's an
important thing to hear and think about
I hope that's wrong but I currently I
could agree with you that unfortunately
you do have to have to be more specific
sort of these deep understandings of
physics and yeah of the way this world
works and also the human dynamics like
you mentioned pedestrians and cyclists
actually that's whatever that nonverbal
communication is some people call it
there's that dynamic that is also part
of this common sense right and we're
pretty we humans are pretty good at
predicting what other humans are gonna
do and how are our actions impact the
behaviors of yes this is weird game
theoretic dance that we're good at
somehow and work well the funny thing is
because I've watched countless hours of
pedestrian video and talk to people
we humans are also really batter our
take
relating the knowledge we have right
which is a been a huge challenge yes
you